foreign
Fernando asks what
I should do to get out of my dad's house
and out of debt while looking to get
married
Fernando you got a lot going on man I'm
a manager for a financial institution
call center making 68 000 before taxes
and have 9 000 bucks in my 401. I still
live at my dad's house and I pay the
utility bills I'm looking to move out of
my dad's house but Arizona home prices
are still high I have over twenty
thousand dollars in debt spread between
credit cards past due taxes set up on a
payment plan and 401K loans
I believe my dad would
hey taking up 401K loans I believe my
dad may be able to lend me money to
knock out some credit card debt that
would help a lot since I'm paying over
25 percent APR rate however I've never
asked him for anything since I was 14
years old I guess except for a place to
live and rent
I'm not sure if I should ask my dad for
money or how to ask him if I do
oh Fernando Fernando oh Fernando we have
no clue how old Fernando is I don't
think he mentioned that he could be 50
he could be 20. that's right no clue
we're gonna guess he's closer to 20.
let's let's pretend let's just for the
sake of this let's just pretend he's 25.
all right okay 25. so he's got a job uh
making 68 making 70 grand
um at a financial calls institution and
he wants to move out okay so he makes
enough money right now that he could go
get an apartment and get his call center
job and deliver for Amazon in the
morning or deliver for whatever and
start working multiple jobs to get this
stupid debt paid off he could
um make a really clear plan with his old
man and say I'm gonna live here for
um three more months I'm gonna have zero
I'm just gonna pay the utility bills I'm
gonna spend no dollars and I'm gonna
start wiping this debt out as quick as I
can I can come up with a plan like that
but he's trying to looks like sounds
like he's trying to do everything all at
the same time he wants to
not live at Dad's house but not have
some debt but also try to invest buy a
house I got some Investments but I had
to take some loans out against my
investments he just got too much going
on at the same time right yeah there
That's a classic case for most people
they don't know why they're not making
progress they're frustrated and they lay
out all the details on paper and you're
like well you could stop doing that and
that and that and that and focus on one
thing with intensity which is getting
out of debt that should be your next
goal which means we're pausing investing
uh which means we're not going to take
out any more debt which is only
exacerbating the problem and so the way
to free yourself from your dad is not to
ask him for a loan so that you can move
out but move out but still be chained to
him with payments exactly that's not
going to help the relationship so
imagine going to the gym George
this is I'm trying to go there which is
quite the stretch I get it all right but
imagine going to the gym do I have to
work out well yeah that's that's kind of
the point of this this whole little this
little story I'm telling you go to the
gym and you get underneath a squat bar
and
you pick up one dumbbell for curls and
you attach one of your legs to one of
those little band things and you do this
on a treadmill right you're gonna you're
not gonna you're not gonna get in good
shape doing that you're gonna get a lot
of broken bones and you're gonna go
nowhere you might look really cool you
would not absolutely would not I think
it's very similar man like you're trying
to do everything all at one time I love
that like get out of debt first dude get
out of debt make a plan to get out of
your dad's house
um and go from there yeah because on
paper I'm going you make 70 grand you
have 20 grand in debt you can do this
there's people who make less with more
debt that have paid it off
a financial institution call center
which is it's I love the way he said
that a financial institution call center
okay um
he could do that he that job is is going
to be shift oriented like I'm working
the night shift and working the day
shift so you've got plenty of time to
work like crazy on another one two or
three jobs figure it out absolutely